hey what's up guys welcome to get close
today we have a very special guest and
one of my favorite people but i don't
think i've ever told him that
timothy
what's up guys what's up dudes what's up
yeah you did uh it's the the second the
first t it's not a that so it's just
chan chantarang su chantarong
chantarongsu yeah
that's the latina that's the race
all right i'm your host geo
uh bart and i'm not racist like the
other host bro
what i'm not racist at all
i didn't even say it like that
do you like people calling you timothy
or tim so i mean i've said um i've said
this on jk news before
i probably wasn't there what show is i
never heard of it
some [ __ ] i use it no one watches it
some [ __ ] dude
but my my real name is actually tim
that's it just him yeah is that from
like how are you surprised you were on
that episode we but you guys you know
it's so much talking all day yeah you
know i feel like you get conversations
mixed up all the time yeah right but a
tim like him uh do you know his full
name uh bartana too
that's a sick name bartona tube see how
he didn't add the extra hard t
it was
very pcl
now do you know his full name no what do
you think it is
i don't know
but uh it's not bart
no it's barton
barton oh i feel like i've heard that
once in my life yeah cuz my dad just
made some [ __ ] up no that's cool barton
i guess so
[Laughter]
it's not cool like from first grade all
the way until you get your ass kicked
until [ __ ] i don't know until bart
simpson came out and then people started
calling me bart man and i'm like yes
finally
they're not calling me bartender i mean
growing up like chantharangsu i heard
everything from uh tim chattanooga tim
chimichanga tim tim got the wrong soup
tim chant the wrong song nice
they got bars man
and then there's people that just go
team
you know a lot of that it's funny when
you're a kid like you hear things like
oh man what'd you call me that man
why are you gonna see i got the wrong
soup that's not cool
this guy was crying because he called
him bartender yeah yeah there's this one
kid i think his name was hank or henry
or something yeah and he would call me
barton i'd get so pissed i'm not a
bartender i don't even know what a
bartender was that's [ __ ] cute in the
life of the parties yeah i was just like
we're sensitive when we're kids you know
yeah yeah no i get it i got my got my
fair share of disses is that a christian
school too
damn christians
no but i'm super stoked to have you here
um
because you're actually someone that i
can't speak for bart but you're actually
someone that i really admire and i
actually really look up to well thanks
geo i really do i don't know if i've
ever told you this but like there's
things happening in life sometimes where
i'm like
what would tim do in the situation and
this is like some real [ __ ] just because
as a person like
um you're just like the coolest dude
like you either [ __ ] with people or you
don't and if you don't [ __ ] with people
it's usually like but you still keep it
really cool like you're still very nice
you're very cordial um you always give a
helping hand and as a person i've always
been like
i like this guy this guy's really really
dope well thanks geo yeah i appreciate
that yeah bart do you feel the same way
honestly yeah no no like uh me and joe
and especially in the early phases of
youtube yeah like me and joe are so
stupid and so like like aggressive for
no reason because we just came out of
like you know like the late 90s early
2000s era so our brains were still in
that space yeah
and then we thought everyone on youtube
was uh um can't say the word anymore
lame dude you don't have to say that
like a flower right like everyone says a
flower
and then we're like man it was a damn
flower and this is a flower like those
shows are flowers like brand deals or
flowers everything is just flowers
and then uh but we would see like you
and i'm like
wait tim's just having friends and he's
not taking things too seriously and he's
just like he'll jump on any collab and
he's just hanging out and he's building
versus we're like literally shutting our
own doors right so even between me and
joe yeah even between me and joe we're
like like you know like those like what
would jesus do bracelets yeah we might
do when you're what would tim do like
now we'd get like an email yeah and then
like they'll be like oh you want to go
do this oh you [ __ ] flower
okay what what is what would tim do i
think tim would do it let's do it
yeah well you know what it was like uh
well thank you guys first of all thanks
for the kind words i just always felt
like
you know um i try not to burn any
bridges or i try to be nice to everybody
just because
um like like you said i don't
necessarily [ __ ] with everybody like
that yeah you know what i'm saying like
there's not a whole lot of people
i let in
in terms of like my close
circle not
available
people don't realize the difference
being cool with people and like and just
like letting everybody you know they
feel like if you if you are cool with
somebody then you have to like be best
friends and [ __ ] yeah um and i just kind
of look at everybody you know hey uh
we're cool we can we can be we can we
can hang out uh you know we can grab a
drink
um
and in terms of like collaborating
i would always kind of be like i'm just
down to work you know what i'm saying
and um
mind you if i found if i thought
somebody's
stuff was just like so trash and cringe
then i you know there's definitely
people i've been like oh no maybe you
know i mean i don't have time
yeah it's really good
yeah there's definitely people i i
curved you know just cause um
i just want to be nice yeah yeah no
um and if if i don't know why no one
would know who you are but
in the event that you don't know who tim
is not timothy
tim is
um let me just go through this roster of
what just what what this guy's about all
right so you know what's really cool
before i even do that um the first time
i saw you was uh the kanye west cover
that you did oh first asian boy yes yeah
um i was barely still the banger it
still goes pretty hard yeah it's a
really good song and like at that point
i was like that's the first asian rapper
that raps on beat that's crazy did you
call him a flower too
probably i hate her ass probably
[Laughter]
i wasn't even with bart yet oh [ __ ] um i
remember i was with my ex-boyfriend and
then he's like you gotta check this out
and then that song came on and and there
was like a hispanic chick with you and i
was like why look at this this is crazy
and i had this like it blew my mind
cause like i had never seen
um it like an asian guy ever do anything
like that
yeah uh that was my first so if y'all
don't know if y'all don't know uh the
blue one dude if y'all don't know um bag
i just had to be like 2 000
seven
maybe like 2008-ish
um
and i was with my ex
uh ileana
and um that's nice i just i mean i knew
that but i just don't want to put that
out yeah that was fun all right
and uh i did a i wrote like a parody of
american boy by estelle and kanye west
was called first asian boy and i was
just kind of like saying all the reasons
why girls should date asian guys if you
never have and but also i was also like
flipping stereotypes like making it like
um
making it like taking it and and making
it a a positive you know yeah like
embracing it a little bit yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so um that and but also i
wanted to make it a funny parody but i
also wanted to like have bars you know
what i'm saying like i was like spitting
on that [ __ ] you know yeah you did
so
um that was my first video to ever go
kind of viral for sure it was my first
one that like
a lot of asian websites kind of picked
up and like where people were
sharing it a lot and it was the first
one that i got got me recognized in
school because i was going to cal state
long beach and i was walking around and
that was the first time someone was like
oh youtube asian asian the youtube asian
song you know yeah and uh and yeah man
i'm still i'm still proud of that [ __ ]
to this day it's good
it's it's the only song to this day for
the past like however many years i've
been doing live shows from the youtube
[ __ ] that i perform like i close with
that show with that song every time oh
damn because it's one of those songs
that like
it's funny and also it's bars
and uh nostalgic too yeah it makes
people feel good you know yeah it makes
my asian boys proud yes
that's so dope that's awesome um and
since then you've continued with youtube
you have like four almost 4.5 million
subscribers on just one of your channels
thanks that's [ __ ] amazing you've
been on mtv you were on wild and out
good job social blade
are you talking [ __ ] to me i'm just
doing my job [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
i didn't give him the stats i didn't say
how many he's like getting every hour oh
yeah don't read that one i got
tourette's i just got it i just got
satisfied
um you were on deliciousness is that so
is that so good yeah we actually nice um
i i i don't know if i'm allowed to say
like details but yes it's still going
nice yeah you're killing it you guys got
green lit for a second season you can't
see it so that was uh we we did the
second season and uh without i'm not
sure what i'm allowed to say but
yes but we're good we're good but maybe
we're good for more yeah that's awesome
dude that's sick man it's a blessing for
sure yeah you're definitely um my
favorite on there
thank you
what about kelly kapowski
no she stole my man all right so no no
zach was mine oh man um
uh you do send foods i just send foods
with david yeah yeah it's a food it's a
food um you guys go around and you try a
bunch of food uh because you and david
are both big foodies um you are he's a
big foodie i'm a smaller foodie he's a
huge foodie dude he's an extra large
foodie
um you you're a co-owner of uh apparel
brand yes brand goody brand yes yes that
thing is [ __ ] sick thanks that's the
hoodie this is
you're weird it's okay
[Laughter]
it's okay you know it's like you see
he's nice i don't like you that's how
i'm not in that seat
yeah man uh yeah i'm glad goodie brand's
doing you know goodie banana was kind of
a struggle at first it's kind of hard to
do clothes i mean i feel like you guys
have such a loyal fan base i think
people love the barbell [ __ ] so hard
especially like because it's you guys
have clothes but it's for a reason too
you know what i'm saying like the
workout [ __ ] yeah to be like when we
were just trying to be like hey man i'm
trying to make cool clothes that that
wasn't um branded as me because you know
i
i feel like i was selling tim branded
merch for a while which did well but
then me and rick were like let's make a
like a clothing brand that has nothing
to do with youtube and it was kind of a
struggle at first for sure but we
finally got a good like rhythm and
people are kind of it's always nice when
people that don't watch me on youtube
are like oh where'd you get that you
know what i'm saying that's what i'm
like okay that's lit you know no this
shit's really fire yeah you guys are
coming out some sick stuff i like those
uh shorts it's almost like a paisley but
like thai pace oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh i love those yeah yeah those are
dope i like those thanks man
those are our moy thighs my thighs
who comes up with the names
it's all the group chat [ __ ] hell yeah
um okay i'm not even done yet so you do
a bunch of original music we just talked
about uh one of you the ones the one of
the first ones that went viral you just
released one i want to see a few months
back or the beginning of the year
um
and that one got like millions of hits
well the one i did with uh with russell
formerly known as deep pride yes that
one did like five mil last year which
was crazy i was like oh [ __ ] people
still [ __ ] with the music that's tight
um i did one with the one i put out this
year did like 300 000 views which wasn't
you know for original music that's
really so hard it's really hard that's
really good i know thank you yeah i just
i try to put i haven't put out like uh
an album and
i had it's almost like 10 years now it's
my last album but i like to drop a track
every once in a while just to remind
people that i i rap so you know what i'm
saying so show them what time it is yes
i'm glad people still like uh [ __ ] with
it yeah no you do a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] um
you also have a podcast no chaser i do
no chaser podcast yes yes with my boy
rick and uh our lovely co-host nikki
blades yes um yeah that's we're doing
that for a couple years now that's fun
yes and okay so if you're already not
busy enough you did say you like working
you just had a baby yeah
the [ __ ] like who do you think you are
bro you're trying to take over
everything
i'm trying to be like you guys
the whole way you're way better same
owner you're way better no no what is
why do people do that here you don't
flip it on us because we're bragging
about you man i'm happy to hear all of
this [ __ ] success i love seeing you
um all over the place like it makes me
so proud to just see like you everywhere
honestly thanks geo i mean that was
always the goal you know what i'm saying
you said you wanted to be like the wool
smith right yeah i was trying to you
know i wanted to be like asian will
smith i mean that's why my original like
stage name was was based off the fresh
prince you know because i was like i
want to be i want to do everything will
smith does like i want to do everything
will smith did tv rap movies
and um you know what she had to get
entanglements
i want i want you to mess around with an
rb singer on the side
you're so dumb
oh but yeah man i was just i'm just i
like working you know and i really want
to just be in everybody's face all the
time you know love it no i love it we
love to see it we love to support it um
that's why i work with people that i
don't like
damn it
ah truth comes out i know i don't know
if he looked at us right now he looked
at me weird
he's like something will eventually pop
off with these losers no i like the jk
guys from the jump yeah i was tired yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
daily harvest
this time of year usually gets super
busy for me because the holidays are
coming up so we got to get ahead on work
and content so we can spend time with
our families and with that means a way
busier schedule and you guys know how
much i love food so the last thing i
want is when i get hungry i'm like oh
what am i gonna eat for lunch what am i
gonna eat for dinner do i even have time
to go to the grocery store i almost have
zero time that's why i love freaking
having daily harvest in my freezer
because it's always stocked up with
delicious options that are ready in
minutes so daily harvest they deliver
delicious harvest bowls
flatbreads smoothies all of that stuff
even overnight oats and they're all
built on organic fruits and vegetables
right to your door and i love love love
that about them because many times when
i'm making meals i'm not making it just
for myself i'm making it for me geo and
our little baby dude taika and so i want
him to have healthy food and that's
what's cool about daily harvest because
they never use preservatives or added
sugar or artificial
anything and that goes for everything
that they have one of my favorites is
their broccoli and cheese harvest bowl
that bad boy is so hardy it feels so
good it warms you up on a cold day and
taika loves it too so if you're like me
you're looking for quick food options
definitely check daily harvest out go to
dailyharvest.com
bell b-e-a-w to get up to 40
off your first box okay up to 40 dollars
off your first box go to
dailyharvest.combail
b-e-a-w
with all the stuff that you have going
on like what do you think
is your
do you have a destination like a clear
picture or you have like a general
direction where you want to go um i you
know i've always
you know
because people will will ask me now
because i'll say [ __ ] like you know guys
like you know i've been i've been doing
this [ __ ] for over 10 years i've been on
youtube for like 15 years
but i'm like i still have so much more
that i want to do and i feel like stuff
that i want to accomplish and people ask
me like well do you feel like you'll
ever be
satisfied you know
and um
at this point
i definitely like i've technically
knocked everything off my checklist
right like in terms of rap like when the
youtube music [ __ ] was popping i mean we
were touring the world yes doing shows
and um and my music's done pretty well
for you know what i've what i've put out
you know um
and like and independently too yeah
independently which is amazing yeah even
before doing independent music was like
really i mean everybody i feel like now
everybody's like everybody's like [ __ ] a
deal you know i just do this [ __ ] myself
but back then it was like kind of new
you know yeah yeah um because everything
digital was pretty new right yeah and
you didn't have all these platforms
where you can do it yourself yeah
exactly i was on [ __ ] i don't know
myspace music uploading tracks oh god my
sister is so good i love it i miss it
because now you could just be like just
on soundcloud and have a straight up
career right yeah i mean and now you can
literally like i mean i feel like back
in the day you put stuff on
if you had something come out on itunes
you're like oh [ __ ] this is legit but
now like literally anybody can put their
music on itunes dude get on [ __ ] tick
tock like you play music on tick tock
one person uses it yeah i know that goes
viral and you're done yeah yeah i mean
hopefully anyway but that christian sex
music we found
what's that
i'll show you later but there's this
like song that i don't even know is
christian yeah but it sounded kind of
like like the lo-fi beats like like
lounge cafe yeah and then the way this
guy was singing he had like this raspy
voice sexy and then yeah he was like
some of the lyrics were like like god
i'll do anything for you and i was like
whoa whoa whoa whoa jesus i'm sitting at
your feet and then he was just singing
it like all like
like he was frustrated we haven't had
sex in a minute too so that might
explain and then i'm like damn and i
sent it to david yeah i'm like yo i'm
like you know christians are behaving
like this and he was like they've been
making music
that's crazy
i mean i've definitely heard some
christian r b nothing that was like sexy
though oh okay now
but yeah
and like i've you know i've been on a
couple like tv shows like cable tv shows
and i've had small parts and movies and
i've done like some independent stuff
but i mean for me i would love to just
take everything i've already done like
next level you feel me like yeah yeah
the music shit's done cool but i'd love
to get like you know like a real ass
like a hit hit
and um
and in terms of tv like okay yeah i've
been on cable but i'd love to do
something on like cbs nbc like network
tv you know and i would love to be like
in a real like blockbuster ass movie you
know what i'm saying so it's like
everything
yeah i've done to an extent but i just i
want to just keep
progressing and keep evolving and and
make [ __ ] happen you know yeah
especially now that i'm like i feel like
i've been working for so long
to
really
get my foot in the door even you know
because i feel like
now just recently past couple years
people have been more open to asians
being in regular roles right yeah um and
so
you know and before i think
a few years ago
people would get like traditional actors
will get irritated by you know digital
people
auditioning for stuff because they'd be
like oh [ __ ] influence yeah
influencers like they
they they're getting parts just because
they have the numbers and blah blah and
some of them can act they got these
movies and they can't even act and um
and like a part of me like yeah agrees
with that yeah yeah it's true obviously
i'm just cheating yeah some shitty
movies for sure i've been in a couple
but like
but also
you know
i also look at it like i grinded for 10
plus years on youtube to have this
these stats as a tool yeah to get me in
the room yeah you know where it's crazy
now where now for certain parts you go
on auditions they're like okay where you
from
where uh you know state your height
what's your name and like how many
followers do you have whoa yeah yeah
i've definitely auditioned for [ __ ] like
that too so you know it plays a part now
where i feel like oh okay
where for the past 10 years they were
looking like oh what is this online
stuff you're doing and now it's you know
it help it helps me get in there you
know so yeah
with all the like
like i think all the stuff that you've
done
i think one of the biggest life-changing
things is becoming a dad for sure and
you know how like that kind of changes
perspective on things like for me a lot
of the stuff i thought i was doing for
like my career or whatever or for myself
but then once you become a dad then it's
almost like if it doesn't benefit me and
the family yeah i don't know if it's
that important
so for you
like
let's say everything went away like all
the hollywood all the
all the people and it was just you and
yourself
maybe it's just you by yourself
like out of all the things that you've
done whether it's in entertainment or
not what's
something that you feel the most proud
of
um my most proud moment
aside from um having my cute little baby
of course
is uh you don't have to say that she
can't hear you
she is cute but she's gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna force her to watch this in a
few years okay good good
um i was probably paying off my my
family's house oh
that [ __ ] made me cry man yeah me too
you know because that was look when i
was
in junior high high school telling my
parents i was gonna you know be in
movies and stuff and you know they
always they always
um
were supportive of of me doing
entertainment they went to all my little
plays and that's awesome and all that
[ __ ] you know so
when i was in high school and like
shortly after high school where i would
be up late doing like little dumb ass
videos with superego
and like we'd be doing our like trying
to film our own movie and like like
really late nights right and my parents
my mom would be like oh why why are you
why are you doing this i'm like trust me
like it's gonna pay off it's gonna pay
off like i'm gonna like i would tell
them i'm gonna pay off your house watch
watch watch right and then um so when i
finally got to a point where i could do
it it just felt like such a um like a
validation for me you know what i'm
saying and like oh and let me tell you
all some [ __ ] if that made you cry let
me tell you something's just gonna make
you cry crying i'm about to cry again
when the when i when i gave my parents a
check for their mortgage or whatever um
you know my dad was like my dad was like
i knew it i knew it and uh yeah right
he's been talking the whole time yeah i
know talk about [ __ ] but he's like i
don't know what i do you could do it
and then but my mom after the camera was
off you know and we're just talking and
she was like she was like finally i can
i can take a break
oh my god i know
and i was like that's when i was like oh
mom and you never knew that i mean i
knew she was tired you know because you
know from the restaurant just from like
life life and like the restaurant and
working um you know because she was
always working like late nights at like
restaurants and stuff before we had our
own restaurant yeah and she was always
complaining about how tired she was and
yeah how much work you know and so she
was like i can finally like rest so i
can finally take a break i was like oh
mom damn
that's [ __ ] what that's when i got
like teary cause like you know shooting
the whole video you know i was like okay
they you know my mom cried in the video
but i wasn't really like tyrion yet
until she said that i was like oh
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] beautiful yeah
i'd be proud of that [ __ ] too now that
she's all like talkative we're like [ __ ]
why did i pay off the mortgage energy
and [ __ ]
with my mom oh she still finds you to
complain about my god
[ __ ] her you didn't even let the tear
come out of my eyes
before you like sucked that [ __ ] back in
now my mom's like she's like i'm so
tired i'm like from what she's like been
working in the garden all day i'm like
you know you don't have to do that
take a nap mom
how cute she's just used to it i think
her parents just get into that mode yeah
and like you take that away from them
and they're like now what do i do that's
my mom right now damn that's dope
that's something man i wish
i can i'll get to a point where i can
like do some like mic drop like sun [ __ ]
like that you know [ __ ] yeah that's what
we want to do one of our goals is we
want to bring our whole family out here
and just be like
for you yeah that's actually like the
real reason why i moved out here
um obviously there's like this the stuff
that people always see on like 10 best
reasons to move out of california you
know like there's like the the list type
stuff but the real real reason is
we want to
be able to change the lives of our
family
and like let's say we want to make a
choice where we're going to all live in
a cul-de-sac or we're all going to do
whatever right the housing prices here
are actually doable
right you know and like
the the way california is i think for us
like if we want to make a decision for
the family it's it stops at our family
right because our the dollar doesn't
stretch that far but like over here if
we could bring everyone over here it's
like oh yeah and we like we'll buy like
three houses because that's the price of
one california house and we can actually
make big decisions and kind of like
bring the whole family together and
that's like the real reason why we moved
here man you know i've been debating uh
like talking to my parents about just
getting them a new house closer to me
and she's house or whatever that'd be
dope it would be dope but at the same
time i'm like i don't think they would
want to move no because my mom put in so
much work into her backyard and her
flowers and [ __ ] even like the other day
i was like because my parents drive a
forerunner from like 2 000 and
stout 2 000
probably but it still runs pretty good
right yeah and i'm like i should get you
guys like a new form you want to do for
runner they don't want any of that i
mean that's like my mom was like yeah
but my dad was like
my dad was like no i don't need it i
like my car you know he's like don't get
it don't get i'm like all right man but
you know like i think they're just so
set yeah for sure
100 that's how it is um like for us we
see like upgrades as like a better you
know like your life's gonna be better
it's gonna be smoother easier and for
them they're like no i already have my
routine i wake up i fart in that corner
i take my pills over there like i have
everything set like don't ruin my [ __ ]
you got her mom a new car oh my god and
then we were like the whole time like
this can be [ __ ] dope she's gonna
love it she has this [ __ ] car it
looks like it's gonna fall apart any
second
so we got a pretty sick car
and when we showed up
we're like it was it for a birthday or
for mother's day or birthday her
birthday they're like hey mom happy
birthday we're like surprised and then
she looks at it she just starts balling
she goes take it back what we're like
you know the camera so he was hiding oh
no like vlogging this whole thing i'm
like carson that was like this i was
like you kept taking a receipt right you
get the hard water refund she thought it
was a waste of money or what
i don't know i think it just so later on
i don't know if you had your talk with
her but having like my own personal talk
with her what i found out was it was too
much of a
like uh like a world or like paradigm
shift okay where she was like you know
you guys are my kids
i always take care of you right and it
was almost like a rude awakening that
like oh wait like
they don't need me to take care of them
anymore they can take care of me yeah
and it almost felt like too much of a
like the world flipping upside down man
you know what's crazy is um speaking of
of that right um i remember
because you know part of the reason of
course why i feel like
people outrage grind so hard is because
we didn't have a lot of money growing up
right and our parents had to work so
hard yep so it's like you know i only
you know i was one of those kids that
only had like one pair of shoes per year
or whatever or like i would wear my
shoes until they [ __ ] had a hole in
them yeah yeah and then so
when i got money i was buying shoes all
the time right and then when i would do
interviews i would say like yeah you
know i kind of think for shoes because
you know my family really couldn't
afford shoes growing up um or like we
had to we were tight with the money
whatever and then um one day i was in
thailand with my dad and i seen a pair
of shoes at some store and my dad was
like and i was about to buy them and i
was like let me get those for you right
and he was like i always felt bad that i
couldn't get you the shoes you wanted
when you were younger and i was like oh
my god and i i was so like
touched but also i was i almost felt
guilty
for all these years
talking about how my parents couldn't
afford shoes you know what i'm saying
that's because they wanted to yeah and i
like i this whole time i was talking
like yeah this is my this is why i grind
this is my motivation because we were
broke growing up but i didn't for one
second think about like oh how does this
make my dad feel that like every time i
say this he's like [ __ ]
my son wanted more shoes and i couldn't
afford to get it so when he said that
even though he was just trying to be
nice she's like yeah yeah let me get
this pair of shoes i feel bad i couldn't
get you the pair of shoes you wanted
girl i was like oh my god
sorry
damn you know damn did you guys get
matching shoes you guys should have got
something
no i was like he bought them for me i
was like these are ugly
nah man but you know i feel like you
know like you said you know the parents
are so set in their ways um that they
don't really even and we're we're just
like we're such a grind mentality we're
like no we gotta you know like why not
get a bigger house like we need a better
house everything's from your perspective
yeah but then you like like when you see
it from your parents you're like oh [ __ ]
it was actually different right i mean
there's that there's like a buddhist
principle right that says uh all
suffering comes from desire so if that's
true if you're never if you're just
happy with what you got then you don't
you don't want other [ __ ] you're not
like you're not like oh i need this i
need that and you're just happy yeah
yeah tell it to the youtube algorithm
the view is just doing by itself god
damn it i need more views it stayed the
same i wouldn't have this desire
you're so dumb that's like when you were
saying that somebody asked you um the
question of like um
like are you ever gonna be satisfied
yeah that already is like asking it in
the wrong way like in my personal
opinion right because it's like it's
like yeah of course you're satisfied
um but it's like what's wrong with just
wanting to elevate it
is that satisfaction you know what i
mean yeah and that's the thing too right
is because people will say um
that
like
if you're never satisfied you know
you're gonna work and work and work and
then you're never gonna get to enjoy
anything you worked for right yeah so i
always try to make sure to keep a
balance
of work and play you feel me because
it's like
i think
of course you can get into this this
habit of of grinding so hard
and then
you know sometimes i i kind of have to
check myself if i'm like working so much
that i can't do dinner with my family or
if i'm away from like chia too much or
something like that i got to remind
myself i'm like okay i'm working hard
but like what am i working for right
it was like oh yeah so i can take care
of my family so i can you know take care
of my wife and my kid right so if if i
can't take a break and actually
enjoy it or like actually
look around and be like oh [ __ ] i'm
doing good like life is good my family's
beautiful this is nice you know then
it's like then it's like oh what's the
point right right um then it's like it's
kind of for my own ego right
but
i still gotta pump that ego too you know
what i'm saying i got [ __ ] i got [ __ ]
i'm trying to get done you know
no i think it's really i think it's
healthy when you're grateful for what
you've accomplished but you're still
down to push more and i don't think at
least if you have like a a healthy
ambition i don't think there's a
destination right because you're still
just exploring parts of yourself right
like let's say you're 40
and you're like oh i did pretty good for
40. they're still going to be 41 or 42
or 45 like you're still years ahead of
you yeah so those years ahead of you are
meant for you to explore and learn more
things about you but i do think when
people are asking for that destination
they probably are just tired too like
[ __ ] when there's all this [ __ ] on it
and i'm tired of grinding right right
right yeah i just you know that's the
thing too i think i just i enjoy
grinding you know and that's one thing
the baby did for me right
is i feel like
i always had so much [ __ ] i wanna do
like i always for like the past few
years i'm like i'm gonna record a new
album i'm gonna write a movie script
right i'm gonna do all this [ __ ] and i
just never got around to it and then
and i think
um
[Music]
i got comfortable right where
i was grinding the hardest in my career
when i was like broke and hungry yeah
and i looked good because i wasn't
eating as much as i eat now yeah yeah
yeah because i was so you know i didn't
i you know i was like i wasn't ordering
the appetizers and the dessert so they
weren't hanging out with david
especially oh man i know um but like you
know my jawline was on point and [ __ ]
but like that's when i was grinding the
hardest you know and i and i had to
remind myself
um there's another saying right it's
like what is it uh it's like comfort is
the enemy of progress or some [ __ ] like
that right yeah so it's like and it
wasn't until and now that i've had the
baby and i'm like okay i have a new
reason to to work hard again you know
because it's like if i really want to
um just give her everything i want to
give her then like okay here's my
motivation to actually get back in the
studio record this album get that
jawline get that jawline back work out i
guess
oh maybe not maybe not i jumped the gun
there oh it's such a struggle well all
my all my [ __ ] that's popping all the
shows that are popping our food shows
so it's like oh that's tough imagine
being jacked and then being on a food
show oh i wouldn't trust that show
i would never watch a future where a guy
was jacked i'm like bro you're not
eating this [ __ ]
that's a good point i like that that's a
good point foods was way better when
david was fat
that's a good point
[Laughter]
with all the like i think people when
they see social media right it's they
call it like their highlight reel
people see wins all the time right and
there's tons of losses that come with it
or even like like false losses or values
that people don't see yeah
in your career or even in your life has
there been like a moment
where you're like [ __ ] and you feel like
like you regret what happened or
something that didn't really go your way
but then later on you're like this made
me who i am and i'm so glad that
happened yeah 100 percent well it's
there was never anything that was like
major yeah that made me like
depressed or anything and made me want
to quit right yeah it was always and i'm
grateful that
me and my crew of of of homies we had a
lot of big fails early on so it was like
i kind of understood that this is just
something that's a part of it right like
when we did back in 2006
we did a rap song called kings of
myspace that went kind of viral for like
for back then
and um as a result of that uh we got
like a small that was a flower video too
this flower ass [ __ ] was
spitting bars in that [ __ ] too and then
uh
i was just a hater
and we so
as a result of that
we uh i mean it was a little flowery as
a result
in a great way um it's funny because all
of me and joe's content are the
floweriest [ __ ] in the world you guys
are smothering each other and hunting i
know it dude
that's great oh but as a result of that
we got like a little movie deal right
yeah and then um
and then that's a little flower i know
but
you know it was so early on and this was
this was high school sucks uh the
musical that never came out and um all
right i could have sworn it came out
we prematurely dropped a few of the
musical segments from that movie and
what what what [ __ ] up was
just to give you some background right
um this was like a first i think this
was the first ever time like a actual
movie studio gave a handful of like
digital dudes some money to do something
i think so yeah and so we
first of all we didn't know how much
money it takes to make a movie and
[ __ ] we just didn't know we're so
ready to sign the contract right
and uh basically halfway into doing it
we ran out of money and uh and we were
like we need more money and they were
like no so we were like all right [ __ ]
it we're not gonna finish it right
so and then it just kind of fizzled off
into the atmosphere and nothing happened
you know what i'm saying and um they own
the rights to it so we couldn't we
couldn't do anything with it um
but since that [ __ ] [ __ ] up so early
on
um
it was a lot of times where
in the beginning i'd be so hyped right
i'm like oh yeah
we i'm about to be in this movie this
guy said he has a part for me in this or
i got this going on i got that going on
and i would tell so many people i get
hyped for it and then it would fall off
and fail or whatever would happen and
then people would be like bro what
happened to the movie right i'm like
[ __ ]
you talk to them yeah i talked to them
much i shouldn't have got people excited
i shouldn't have got excited you know
and i think early on i just learned that
man look there's gonna be
so many auditions i do that i'm not
gonna get
so many deals that
even after i sign this [ __ ] it's not
gonna happen right and so many so many
um
so many opportunities that i thought are
gonna be like my big break that just
fizzle off and die and so i just kind of
learned early on not to get too hyped
and just all i can really do is um just
keep working you know all i can control
is what i do you know and so like i
always tell people there's literally
been like five different movies that
i've i was told i was gonna be the star
of you know i'm saying like [ __ ] where
i've been at the table reads and they've
been like
guys
we didn't get the funding we wanted but
we're gonna do it ourselves and this
movie is happening right and i'm like
lit or like movies where they're like
all right man you're like i heard that
four times already like legit where
they're like here's the script for this
movie we want you for it we got it's a
it's a it's like we got j cole he's
ready to go and it's like all this [ __ ]
i was supposed to fly to india with rick
to shoot another movie like all this
[ __ ] that just didn't happen right yeah
and so i just
um
i just kind of learned early on you know
just you know you just gotta just gotta
keep on keep on doing what you do the
first audition i ever got was wilding
out
that was the first yes i got were you
like oh this is easy every audition i've
done but just get it well not really
because um
without that one i already auditioned
many times before that i had done a few
oh i said a few auditions
i thought you like the first audition
you ever got you ever auditioned for oh
no no that was the first one that got a
yes
yeah um but that one was lit because
well here's the thing i think i'm a i
think i think i'm not a good in-room
scripted auditioner to be honest yeah
like if someone
has a part from me like i always kill
this [ __ ] right like and i remember one
time i was on set for something and this
old white dude he was like
let me tell you something when they told
me there was going to be a youtuber guy
being in this i thought oh god but he
was he was like he was like but you can
really act i was like thank you
kind of thank you so much i was really
like appreciative of that you know yeah
because i know there's a stigma around
that right but um
so but so i know i can kill this [ __ ]
but i think in the room i don't
necessarily audition well right it's a
different skill it's a different skill
especially since like it's weird when
there's like you know like three people
just staring at you you're trying to be
funny and they're just coming
right it's like they're reading the
lines to you hella dry super dry and
then i yelled rape rape help me and
you're like i'm supposed to cry in this
scene you're not motivating me at all
this doesn't get you're giving me
nothing here yeah
so yeah so when i got all when i got
while i'm out it was dope well
especially since that was more it's i
don't have it's not scripted it was just
me like you know rapping and improvising
making jokes and [ __ ] so that was cool
um but
for scripted [ __ ] you know i'm still
really trying to
find my groove i probably only booked
like a couple
couple scripted little things here and
there but i'm working on it
so you're trying to do like you're
trying to hit if possible the music the
acting
uh what's up the space
tv movie oh okay okay the the rat the
you know at this point the the music for
me is um
is more just because i like doing it um
i'm not necessarily trying to get a hit
especially since i feel like
you know um
like
the music
that's a radio hit necessarily isn't
like
it's not the music i do you know i like
being witty and [ __ ] like i like yeah i
like spitting bars so i feel like
radio [ __ ] you know it's it's not people
aren't listening for lyrics necessarily
yeah it's a way different like type of
music yeah so when i when i write raps i
just kind of enjoy doing it like when i
make music it's it's now now it's more
so for me
um
and uh
and and just also because i feel like
rap a lot of commercial rap got so
trashed over the years that i feel like
um really mediocre writing is like oh my
god fire emojis you know what i'm saying
so i'm like oh man i wasn't motivated to
start rapping again until i heard like
trash music and i was like oh god i need
to start rapping again you know so it's
more for me just just because i like
doing it and i and i like uh i like
putting words together and [ __ ] yeah but
as far as
but my i would say my main priority is
uh yeah acting and trying to write this
movie god damn it i'm writing a movie
for me and david but it's taking me
forever
do you think since like you've been
through so much and you know that
like you just gotta keep putting like
one foot in front of the other for
success there's nothing that's
guaranteed to be successful do you think
um like let's say nothing ever pops off
the way that you want but you still keep
pushing the needle right because i think
as as long as you work hard there will
be more and more projects
um but it might not ever be like the big
banger project you're looking for right
you think that's something that uh
you'll you'll be satisfied and happy
with well you know what i feel like at
this point
in my career right and this is one of
those moments where i i can
look back let's say nothing
huge was like pop off right i of course
can still look at my life and being like
man i did well for myself [ __ ] yeah um
you know i think at the end of the day
um
i'm glad i just put in like maximum
effort and and pursued
what i wanted to do and was able to
make something happen you know what i'm
saying um
and the fact that i could actually be
somebody who like rep for my asian dudes
and my asian peoples and like
um wasn't out there being a stereotype
you know i'm saying like
uh
and i put out stuff i could be proud of
and i was able to you know take care of
my family and stuff um yeah i i would
have like i would be totally happy with
what i've done that's awesome is
carrying like the asian
like
like killing that stereotype and
reframing everything is that like
something that's really big that you
carry with you yeah i mean that's
originally why i kind of got into
like really the entertainment industry
you know what i'm saying because i
remember because you know how like okay
my my old stage name is from the fresh
prince right yeah and i remember
fresh prince being my favorite show
growing up and then watching
and then the one
time or the first time i saw an asian
dude on the fresh prince ever
it was this episode where carlton
his tux had shrunk at the dry cleaner
before prom
and um he had to wear like a baby blue
like ruffle stupid like dumb and dumb or
tucks right right oh okay and then he
was all embarrassed
and this group of nerds walks by and
they have similar tuxedos on and the
asian one was like hey carlton nice tux
and i was like oh [ __ ] never seen an
asian guy on fresh prince until right
there and it's a [ __ ] nerd in a
stupid tux and i'm i remember thinking
if this is the first time i've ever seen
an asian guy then this is the first time
everybody that watches the fresh prince
who doesn't grow up around asian people
this is the first asian person they've
seen on tv you thought all of that yeah
because i want yeah because i remember
thinking like
other people see this and this is their
only perception of asian guys you know
what i'm saying and i was like that's
not me
and this is you in high school it's like
i don't know like fifth sixth grade god
damn that's pretty deep that's really i
guess so you know and i just remember
thinking like i need to i need to change
that you know and then and then of
course there was another episode with
dante bosco who you know dante i feel
like dante was doing doing he was he was
breaking stereotypes before all of us he
didn't really look asian though
i was like half but you could tell he
was asian yeah i was still i would see
dante pop up i'd be like oh i can do
that yeah if this guy's doing this i can
do that right
and um and you know
uh and so that was definitely one of my
main
goals and a lot of the reasons people
will say like my early videos right were
so like
uh sexual right people were asking why
you always talking about your dick right
like why why is it so much about your
dick all the time and like i always put
out these sexual videos and a big part
of that was
i feel like even though there were a lot
of asian guys on youtube killing it like
you know nigahiga and kev jumba um the
wong fu guys i feel like their their
vibe was still like oh we're awkward
around girls you know what i'm saying
like yeah we're funny and we're
attractive but we're still like i'm kind
of awkward i'm funny like but i'm not
necessarily someone who gets girls right
and i
i never had an issue
getting girls okay growing up say that
out loud okay so i was like let's put
that out there let's talk about like my
sexual experiences let's talk about my
dick to kind of provide oh this is a
sexual asian dude who like
smashes the vagina
regularly nice and it's not awkward you
know what i'm saying and it's like and i
just i really wanted to emphasize that
part
of my life for
my
like asian people asian peoples you know
yeah uh but you were fifth and sixth
grade when that was like a such a
[ __ ] deep profound thought prior to
that though
i mean would you make fun of or did you
just notice differences where you're
like hmm
why am i getting asked these questions
or why am i not like that or well i was
i was blessed enough so i went to school
in gardena you know what i'm saying and
my school was fairly diverse it was like
mainly black and asian uh with some
latino and white sprinkled in there and
um and yeah there were like there were
jokes here and there but it was nothing
i never felt bullied i never felt picked
on for being asian you know um
to the point where when i went to
paramount high and i was one of the only
asian dudes people were kind of um well
the first time someone tried to like say
some asian jokes to me and i like
clapped back they were like oh they were
like taken back by her right they're
like oh he's not like those nerd and
fresh princess
like they weren't expecting it you know
and then when they heard i rap it was
always dudes trying to call me out to
battle
during lunch that's when traffic came
yeah well actually
here's a fun little tidbit of
information yeah in high school
the homie that i used to rap with his
his name was cameron but he was calling
himself traffic and i was actually
calling myself tickets so we were
traffic tickets that's tough ticket was
my rap name that i was telling people in
high school for a little bit um and then
after we graduated i was like he stopped
rapping i was like i'm gonna take
traffic all right
good call i think i think you made a
good call right but uh so so people
would like always challenge me to rap
and [ __ ] during lunch and then you know
so it was always like stereotypical
jokes but it was always it was all jokes
you know and um
so for me growing up i was fortunate
enough that it was i never actually felt
bullied you know i definitely remember a
couple jokes early on like when i was
really young where i was like i was like
oh i can't believe that kid just said
that you know but
uh
but
i i it was never
to a point where i was like oh my god
i i'm feeling i'm feeling racially
attacked you know what i'm saying which
i feel like i i was i'm blessed to have
that experience right yeah yeah um
but i i definitely wanted to i knew
there were asian kids out there that
maybe didn't know how to clap back right
so
that's why i was glad you know because
kids would ask me in dear delegates and
[ __ ] like oh what do i say when someone
says this
you know like what do i say when people
are saying this and this and that to me
try to plagiarize my [ __ ] clap backs
dude hey i wasn't even mad
that's why when i went a while and out
um you know people you know they would
make
asian jokes i bet it must have been
tough because when they're like when
they know they're going to go up against
you in the last segment yeah people
probably have like oh i got a whole list
of [ __ ] for tim
so it's probably felt like one versus
ten people well that was the struggle
was because you know when they're coming
at me it was never tim jokes it was
always asian yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i mean it was it was the
occasional like uh pimple joke or like
short joke but majority time was asian
jokes right yeah and i
like most of the time couldn't clap back
with black jokes if i'm making jokes i'm
talking about their outfit i'm talking
about specifically like carlos's beard
or something like that right i'm not i'm
not making black jokes
why not
you know here's the thing right here's
the thing here's why i also think
growing up in a diverse
area helped me because i feel like um
black jokes work
if you do them right yeah like [ __ ] i
think all jokes work if you do them
right yeah and that's the thing because
but it's like someone will make like on
the wilding house stage someone can make
a
uh fried rice a fried rice joke and
it'll kind of hit like people might
laugh right it's more ignorant than
anything right because because you don't
really
um first of all
they're not really hearing those jokes
on tv like that right so it's like oh
tim delivers fried rice whatever it's
gonna get a little ju go get some laughs
if i make a fried chicken joke it's not
really funny yeah it's kind of played
out yeah right so yeah that [ __ ] doesn't
really work so i you kind of have to be
smarter with it right you gotta be smart
next level with it yeah like i would
like like for example me and carlos went
back and forth one time and he has some
really like patterned pants on i said he
looked like an african genie or some
[ __ ] like that
and that and actually worked right um
and i think i had to be more creative
with it because and also when they were
coming at me of course it's like full
out asian jokes so i i'm not defending
myself i'm defending like almost like my
whole
race of asian dudes that's right
um but i think it was it was helpful for
me because some dudes will be like on
the [ __ ] chat rooms like oh tim was
on stage on a while now letting them say
those racist jokes to him oh my god he's
a he's in he's an uncle wong right
and i'm like bro do y'all not watch the
[ __ ] show do you not hear me clapping
back at like every joke like every time
they had a joke for me i had a rebuttal
for it and that's because i grew up
where we were always cracking jokes at
each other you know it's like where i
was i didn't i didn't like cry about it
i was i would clap back you know
and i think that was that was good i
think people could watch while now and
appreciate that like oh okay uh
tim was ready right and that actually
made it more difficult for me later on
in the in the um seasons because
people stopped coming after me like it
was easier when they would attack me
with asian jokes and i would rebuttal
because the audience is on my side yeah
but then when they knew that i had
clapbacks people stopped coming for me
so then i'd have to be like
yo well i'd have to attack people first
and then people are less on my side you
know i'm not like oh [ __ ] now i'm the
buoy yeah yeah but yeah
damn um so you've always been sorry if
you had a question uh but you've always
been like the super positive dude
like everything you're even explaining
right now like there's always like this
really so like this really dope silver
lining that you paint every situation
that you've been in like you're like i
re he asked you this deep regret [ __ ]
question and for the most part people
can usually go into this dark place and
be like [ __ ] i really regret that but
for you you're like yeah i regret that
but it helped me here and it made me
good here like where do you get that
from
man i honestly feel like
early on
somehow
i decided in my brain
that like
i knew life was short right
i knew that like
you could you could you could die at any
time
that didn't hit me till like last year
really like like obviously i know that
yeah yeah but like like really hitting
the weight of it yes like literally like
i can remember the moment that it hit me
it was taika was helping me clean some
produce yeah because i was cooking and
that was his job to clean it yeah so i'm
watching this happen and like i have
like an outer body experience and i'm
watching him do it i'm like
dude like this is a lot this is the only
time this is ever gonna happen i'm like
i could die right now right like and
this will never exist again and that
that like
killed me mm-hmm but you had that when
you were really young i mean i think
it's because i just watched a lot of
movies maybe like [ __ ] we're like you
know it's it's a wonderful life where
you know the guy like you know and i i
realized really young that like dude
life is short like why
why stress out about like about [ __ ]
for you know like why i worry about
things i can't change when i could
literally die any day right so i just
didn't let
things
bother me like that like i felt like if
something
[ __ ] up happened
then i'd be like okay yeah this was
[ __ ] up but i'm gonna try and like
move on trying to look at the bright
side because i really want to enjoy life
while i have it you know what i'm saying
and um
and i always i just never wanted to ever
like
regret anything or like
waste
life you know did your parents complain
a lot or like uh were they always people
that were kind of stuck in a place that
you like saw that and you're like
yeah i'm gonna learn from that and do
the opposite i mean look my mom is
definitely cuz she could be a
complaining ass mom i feel like like
most moms are they tend to complain and
nag whoa whoa whoa whoa
older moms older moms yeah
and um well you know i've even been
accused of not caring enough about
things but i've always just felt like
you know what man i feel like if you
just kind of just trust the universe and
god like [ __ ] will work itself out
um and and i always just kind of let let
let it work itself out it always does
you know what i'm saying and and
and i always like
and i used to say this in my duty
ghettos right in terms of like
approaching girls but you can apply this
to life too right because dudes would
ask me like man what do you do and
there's like a girl and you want to talk
to her but like
but but but you're too scared right and
i just remember i always go back to this
one time i was at the mall when i was
like in fifth sixth grade i saw this
beautiful girl at the van store i
remember specifically she had like
big like curly hair and she had like uh
i think she was part asian but she was
so hot and i wanted to go talk to her
like in sixth grade and like get her
number however that was and i was like
working up the nerve
and then but i couldn't do it and then
like ten minutes later i went back to
the vans looking for it and she was gone
and i remember thinking like oh that's
that one that got up the one that got
away that could have been my wife right
and from that point on i was like man
who the [ __ ] cares if i get rejected if
i feel stupid for five minutes it's
better than going the rest of my life
and being like what if you know already
at [ __ ] sixth grade who the [ __ ] are
you well it was just me trying to like
feel on a booby or something you know
i'm saying like i could have felt on her
boobies but i was like still that's so
profound
i was just i was very driven by my
horniness at a young age good for you
but then i realized later on you can
apply that to life you know what i'm
saying because it's like so many things
in life where
you don't do because you're afraid of
rejection you're afraid of looking
stupid and then you might look back on
that and be like [ __ ] man i missed out
on the opportunity to to experience
whatever that could have been you know
dude i mean you have the big hair curly
almost half asian like she's downstairs
you married her bro i know but yeah and
of course you know and then everything
happens for a reason i found chia she's
the best have my little baby there she's
the best yeah she's like she's exactly
like you no chia i know no chia in there
well um she has ears she has she's oh
cute okay i really liked her ears
because my earlobes connect and
it's crazy you notice all these little
things like lip shape nose fingers toes
yeah yeah that was one of the things
when tiger came out because i have like
those toe thumbs that people swear i'm
embarrassed by they're like they're like
um
yeah you'd like try to hide them i'm
like no not really your thoughts don't
look toei to me no they're suit like i
have like those half
toe thumbs i guess i see what you're
saying um uh yes but that was one of the
first things i'm like does he have like
like my thumbs or bart's thumbs and then
like flat-footedness bart's flat-footed
i'm flat-footed
[Laughter]
doesn't have flat feet he got my arches
ah lucky guy yeah
no but damn as as a little ass kid man
like you're a deep ass thinker was that
the only moment that you regretted and
then that just drove the rest of your
life have you experienced any other big
forms of regret before that
um
no
wow that's awesome i just you know
at the end at the root of it all it was
always just a like let's live life to
the fullest let's not dwell on the
negative [ __ ] because i just feel like
it's a waste you know what i'm saying
and um and and and look
um
i would be uh remiss to not point out
the fact that nice does that mean it
means like just kidding okay cool uh
he's like i don't know either
thank god she's just [ __ ]
um it's like of course
i've been blessed to not really
experience anything super traumatic in
my life right like
um you know i mean it depends i mean
like i hear when people say that and
sometimes i'm just like
there's no reason to even have to say
that right because like [ __ ] that some
person can handle maybe you can't handle
or they can't handle yeah you know what
i mean so like
i don't even know if it's if it's if if
you even need to say that's true because
some people
if they had a movie that was half made
and it wasn't completed that might have
crushed their entertainment dreams
forever and they would have stopped they
would have been like that's why i was in
traumatic i you know i'm a computer guy
now that's that's very true and you know
what that's facts too man because you
know uh when people always like people
ask like how are you
like how did you get to where you're at
right and a lot of [ __ ] hard work
man i feel like it's majority hard work
and like determination and dedication
and [ __ ] because i always tell people
like look man
i'm not i'm not that funny like i'm
funny that's true
i'm not like the funniest person right
and i'm like
but at the end of the day i think
i know what i wanted and i kept working
towards it and i never like let up even
if it was like baby steps i kept working
towards it right and also and that's the
thing i'm easy to work with so people
[ __ ] with me yeah um
and i feel like uh you know because
there's definitely people who who might
be talented but it's like oh god dude
that's a [ __ ] i don't want to work oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and um
and i've definitely been on sets where
they're like oh god yeah thank god you
know what you're doing because those
viners we were working with
god nightmare they can't read a [ __ ]
teleprompter teleprompter to save their
life right and i'm like i think i'm just
uh uh my positive attitude has helped me
uh
in my life brother not yet not only get
work but um
the fact that i feel like [ __ ] i don't
want to waste time
uh
dwelling on dumb [ __ ] dwelling on dumb
[ __ ] i i can just keep working you know
yeah so yeah with all the stuff that you
have and skills and
things that you've gone into like let's
say you had a chance to
redo
your whole journey
with the same skill set and then the
knowledge that you have now
you think you would have taken the exact
same steps or whether it be things that
you would have changed
or even a different career
i don't
think
i would change
anything because i trust
the path that i'm on right yeah even
though even even one time
like i i was doing i was on camera on
stage's podcast one time and he asked me
something about like uh if i wish
everything i wanted to do like all like
the big movie stuff like if i wish it
had popped off when i thought it was
gonna pop up pop off like with like
early 20s you know and i think about
that and
i actually i'm kind of glad i'm not at
the level i mean yeah it's easy to say
that but i'm glad i'm not at the level
that i expected to be when
i expected to be because let's say i was
early 20s [ __ ] huge movie star pop
star whatever right
like i probably
wouldn't have met chia
um i probably wouldn't have got to like
really like take my time and
enjoy my early 20s like i did i feel
like i have so many great experiences
especially like
being able to kind of uh go on tour
during like my 20s as a that was nice
yeah like as a pop and youtuber um but
like you know you're not really famous
yeah so it's like you get still have
your life and your privacy yeah you
still kept your life in your privacy you
get to you know actually go places go to
disneyland without getting like really
mobbed and it's like but i also was like
on tour like going in living my best
life and i i like the way everything has
panned out and has happened you know
what i'm saying and i think
how lit is it that now
i'm i'm grown you know
and the asian opportunities are really
starting to open up
and uh and i have a wife now so i'm not
gonna get some random girl pregnant
you know what i'm saying smashing random
groupies
and i think everything i just trust the
timing of everything you know i don't
think i would redo
anything
that's dope man yeah i appreciate you
really thinking about that
it's a good question i could hear you
going like
damn would i
yeah i mean it's hard to even answer
that honestly because it's like
you really don't know what that timeline
would look like right you know you
really don't know if like maybe you
still through some crazy circumstances
don't met chia you know what i mean who
knows what with the multiverse weird
let's say the multiverse split off and i
had a super popping off like one of my
let's say first asian boy hit the radio
and i got a record deal and i was like
imagine right and then me and chia
didn't like link the way we did back
then right
who knows maybe i would have
um
done like a movie premiere at the
toronto film festival while she was
there with one of her cousins and then
hooked up with her one night and got her
pregnant last year and then we had veda
all the same multi-universes
the exact same way who knows man i mean
multiverse that's a movie script right
there yeah facts i mean everyone's doing
multiverse [ __ ] now
flower ass multiverse
but yeah man you know it's like i think
um i just i just trust the process and i
trust like
life you know and i trust uh the
universe and god and
everybody i love how you like
like when we talk about ourselves um we
tend to downplay a lot of our own [ __ ]
because i mean who sits there and really
like thinks about how great they are
right right but from like an outside
perspective yes you're saying like oh i
keep a positive mindset i'm easy to work
with whatever but from the outside like
um you
you you set boundaries you speak up when
you need to speak up you're authentic
you're true to what you say like
um
like i think all of those things stack
up and that's why you end up
obviously the work ethic and and all of
that but it's all these little things
that like get put together that allow
you to do all this stuff
i try to speak up when i should speak up
i probably could speak up a little more
i think she is good better at that for
me you know what i'm saying like i'm i'm
i'm i'm actually a little too laid back
sometimes but i'm like ah [ __ ] it it's
fine and she was like no we're getting
our money back i'm like all right fine
go you you handle that
oh my god that's good that's all it's
fine i don't feel like i don't feel like
making the phone call she's like no [ __ ]
that you know i'm like okay cool you
handle that babe i mean i get that yeah
uh like if it's something like that i
understand because you're you also have
a status you know what i mean like
especially if they know you yeah and
like they're a fan or some [ __ ] and then
you're complaining not complaining but
yeah yeah yeah it could be seen as i get
that right but i'm talking about [ __ ]
that matters
like when it matters i don't see you as
someone that's just gonna like not say
anything about it i will write a strong
email that's strongly worded yo i can
write a [ __ ] email bro let me tell
you because i was almost uh
an english an english major just because
i love like words and like and grammar
so much i actually really enjoy like
that wow
like diagramming i don't know if you all
ever diagram sentences in school no i i
[ __ ] had friends dude
it's the thing we did in english class
you put the noun on a line you put the
line and the verb here and then you put
the adverbs under anyways you diagram
sentences to get the structure of the
sentence i love doing that [ __ ] right i
just and i just like english and so i
like writing actually and um so when
it's time for me to [ __ ] write an
angry email like a professional yet like
passive aggressive email i'm like let's
[ __ ] oh my god
yeah
yeah i had to do that one time went to
like because this company owed me money
because we had like a guarantee in the
contract and they were [ __ ] super
dodging me
and um
i had worked with this company for years
so i was like really laying on like the
passive aggressive like guilt trip i'm
like you know just so you guys know i
find it very disrespectful that after
years of working together and building a
relationship you would um you know at
this point i'm finding your absence as a
form of disrespect and i think that you
should announce like one like going in
and i was like and immediately they
replied and like paid me the next day i
was like [ __ ] yeah
and i ended and i was like
[ __ ] at the end you did not
[Music]
sometimes you gotta get it out now this
is gonna get leaked and it's gonna be
worse
for real man i'll do that [ __ ] with
comments sometimes i'm about to go in
and i'm like
nah
i'll reply every time though i'm like
you mother
[ __ ] i like i like when you reply to
people when they say some stupid [ __ ]
and you write you're dumb
no yeah i'm always like don't write some
[ __ ] i'm like i always go
are you dumb
not even are you it's just like you're
dumb and i'm like that is the best
[ __ ] comment but sometimes sometimes
they get so mad like i said literally
the other guys the other day some guy
commented and he said something and i
was like hello are you dumb he was like
wow just because i disagree with you on
something you're going to call me dumb
i've been supporting you for like so
these other years i was like and i i was
like nah i mean why would you blah blah
and he was like okay fine and then i was
like and he's like okay fine i love your
vlogs and i was like okay you are dumb
no no i was like i was like okay fine
you're not dumb sorry
i was like okay maybe i should have
called you dumb i'm sorry
it's hard man most people in the
comments i think they're like
borderline
like like on tilt already yeah so when
they're replying it's not even their
best self that's facts and then
sometimes when you're replying you're
also like i don't know you've been in
traffic or some [ __ ] and then so you're
like
and then like later on like it's like a
knot that could just literally just pull
the string and everything is out and
you're like why did that even happen
yeah and it's the difference between
going back and forth with someone for an
hour or like saying something nice and
then being like my bad bro i was in a
good mood because i'm always in a bad
mood because that's definitely happened
yeah i've literally had people like
years later being like hey man just so
you know
years ago i was talking [ __ ] on your
videos and came across something and uh
i also want to apologize i was like yeah
you know it's like [ __ ] man yeah i guess
it sticks with people huh yeah
i had a guy
uh
who was leaving hater comments on my
[ __ ] for like
i want to say like years like
consistently oh well let's say a year
and let's say his name was uh
barton barton babe
okay all right okay and then he sounds
like a dick
it got to the point where
if i didn't have a hater comment from
barton babe it was weird i was like what
happened to [ __ ] barton babe where's
my [ __ ]
hater comment right and one day i was
doing a meet and greet in vancouver
and and this guy came up to me and he
was like hey man it's me bart and babe
and i was like that's you
this guy doesn't even know he was being
a hater no he was like he's like hey man
look i'm actually a big fan i just like
talking [ __ ] and i was like oh my god
he was like can we get a picture i was
like yeah you've been ruining my day for
years
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] showed up interesting dude i
have a commenter that i absolutely love
it's uh obsolete like a bunch of numbers
and every single post shout out to
obsolete
he always writes look at hoochie papa
doing his torque thing
every single comment
and then um
i forgot what happened
one time he didn't write that i don't
know if it was about like tycho or dogs
or something yeah and he's been doing
this for like years and he just wrote
like ah
like that and then i was like
what yeah are you okay yeah so i replied
i'm like [ __ ] off i wrote something like
like uh
how come obsolete's not doing his
hoochie pop or twerk thing or something
like that and it was just dope that like
there's just this one post because it
could be about anything yeah it could be
about food traveling whatever and it's
always look at hoochie pop
like one of the vlogs on your dog's
dying look at what you probably do
[Laughter]
this guy is awesome
look for him now all right all right no
i'm sure he has time he doesn't have the
time to do that but now man uh last
thing i want to touch on unless you have
something
um is the fact that you've said you've
been on youtube for 10 plus years now
right yep this will be my 15th year
wow
yeah 15 years um and
your mental health seems [ __ ]
fantastic yeah
yeah yeah how do you do that i actually
i don't understand when people uh when
they're like i had to take like a month
break or whatever because i like i said
i here's here's what's important right
for me
uh i think it's super important to keep
a balance you know what i'm saying like
balance your work with your just life
and regular lifetimes i think
a lot of these
uh these these youtubers that like get
burnt out they um
they are like a slave to like the
schedule of it um like daily vloggers of
course i can see how daily vlogging
would would get burnt out that's why i
stopped yeah um
doing it i was probably daily vlogging
for like a couple months before i was
like okay i can't do this anymore yeah
um but i think people
that um
don't let themselves breathe are the
they're like oh my god if i don't get
this up now like what am i gonna do like
i need to crank this out i need to get
this out and get this out that's when
they like they're like they just get
burnt out and there that's when their
mental health struggles because now
um they're not living for themselves
anymore you know true and uh and i think
dude just take a break i mean that's the
like i mean like you don't have to
upload all the time i think that's the
beauty of youtube is like we're our own
boss we make our own schedules you know
and i i always
tried to make sure
um i was like just keeping it balanced
you know what i'm saying
and um
and that yeah that's why i stopped
daily vlogging and uh that's why i i
i've never really even been on an actual
schedule
uh because i just want to just kind of
do this [ __ ] when i want to do the [ __ ]
you know yeah and um
and if people were ever like yo where's
the video was a video i'm like
close my laptop
that's dope
you don't see it it doesn't matter that
you're able to just shut it off and i
think that you know really helps with
the mental health part of it i think
it's super cool some people will shut it
off but then it's still in their brain
you know yeah i mean and it's definitely
in my brain too like if it's been longer
than a couple weeks without going
putting something on my main channel i
get antsy for sure yeah yeah um but you
know i just kind of have to remind
myself i'm like hey man like you're
doing this for you um
and uh i i think it helps that chia is
not
so much uh like uh in this world
personality in this world because
you know especially when vlogging i have
to make sure she's comfortable you know
and uh
and if she's not in the mood then i
don't turn the camera on and i just kind
of just you know like cool let's not do
that especially when i've seen you know
like couple vloggers who are daily
vlogging like
i remember um y'all remember prank
versus prank do you guys know that yes
yeah and they did that whole vlog about
like yo
we've been doing this so much we don't
know if
we vlog because like we love each other
or it's or we're just getting content
you know what i'm saying yeah and i
would never want to get to that point
yeah yeah so uh just a balance healthy
balance yeah i love it i love it i love
it and i love this whole conversation
like i looked at the time and now it's
we're we're done
and i'm like [ __ ] i feel like we just
barely scratched the surface on who tim
is well luckily we have another episode
with dewey
i think so if unless chia wants to leave
right now but i think we're good
well guess what you're here to hear
first we have another episode coming so
we we don't know when we're gonna
release it just yet but it's coming i'm
saying it's coming uh but thank you so
much for tuning in thank you tim
we [ __ ] love you hey i love you guys
too man thanks for having me what is
that
oh damn the the
cake is ready you're talking too much
it's ready
uh yes thank you appreciate you love you
um a big source of of our motivation for
sure at least mine yeah no you guys
motivate me too because i'll look at
like the [ __ ] y'all still got going on
the fact you are gym owners and you got
like all this you going on i'm like i'm
like i should be investing my money into
other [ __ ] i can't close a laptop on the
gym
yes
it's [ __ ] there yeah but no thank you
it was it was a joy having you here man
hey guys uh thank you for having me i
love you guys and uh your house is
beautiful thank you all right thank you
also for watching and we'll catch you
next time